inside the Prime Minister was giving a
speech about preparedness for future
bush fires outside protesters were
beyond angry a month in toxic smoke it's
not anger it's just it's fury it's
something that I haven't felt before we
have a government that is not only in
denial they are promoting fossil fuels
they are promoting coal protesters and
environmentalists say the ferocity of
Australia's fires are evidence of
climate change what frustrates many
Australians is Australian politicians
including the Prime Minister play down
the link between climate change and the
recent bush fires while pursuing
policies that could make climate change
worse Australia exports more coal than
any other country it is the world's
third largest exporter of all fossil
fuel products measured by their
potential to emit carbon dioxide behind
Saudi Arabia and Russia and Australia
plans to grow its export significantly
the government has given approval to the
Indian company Adani to build a coal
mine that was intended to be the biggest
in Australia and one of the biggest in
the world it will initially export 10
million tonnes of coal a year but the
railway from the mine to the coast will
have the capacity to carry 14 million
tonnes a year
protestors fighting the project have
targeted adonys contractors recently
here in Munich outside the German
company designing its railway signalling
system and they've also been
demonstrating against financial backers
making it hard for a Doni to borrow for
the project the company is now financing
it itself and has had to scale back its
initial plans
critics say such projects show Australia
needs to reverse its priorities stopping
new mines would put upward pressure on
coal prices making it less attractive to
burn coal will also incentivize money to
flow into the alternative forms of
energy that we need a Donnie says
criticism of its mining operations is
unfair another company's mines have
government approval to become much
bigger Australia's Prime Minister has
towns damaged by the fires but says he's
committed to protecting mining jobs he
will also not reduce the number of
coal-fired power stations in the world
today by forcing the shutdown of
Australian coal mines and Australian
jobs that go with them so the countries
will just buy the coal from somewhere
else
critics disagree but just as the
bushfire still rage so do the arguments
of over government policy Andrew Thomas
al-jazeera Canberra